All right, now this moment from the life of a teenage girl in these United States.
好了，现在来看看美国少女生活中的这一刻。
School has just let out. Perfect spring day. Kara and her boyfriend, Jeremy, come outside, and he jumps on her back.
学校刚放学，正是完美的春日。卡拉和她的男朋友杰里米走到户外，他跳到她的背上。
Get off me. Jeremy, come on. You're hurting my back.
从我身上下来。杰里米，得了吧。你弄疼我的背了。
You love it.
你很享受。
I don't.
我才没有。
When I recorded this, I'd been doing documentary radio stories on Kara and her friends for two years. So it was natural that at this point, Kara would just turn to me and say--
我录制这段的时候，我已经跟拍卡拉和她的朋友们做纪录片电台节目两年了。所以此时此刻，卡拉自然而然地转向我说——
Ira, kick his butt. Get away from me. You're too violent. Jeremy, stop.
艾拉，教训他一下。离我远点。你太粗鲁了。杰里米，住手。
Well, today on our program, the lives of teenage girls. From WBEZ Chicago, you're listening to This American Life. I'm Ira Glass, back for another week, to kick your butt. Not really. Back for another week documenting everyday stories of these United States using all the tools of radio storytelling-- documentaries, monologues, overheard conversations, found tapes, anything we can think of.
好了，今天我们的节目主题是少女的生活。这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台，你正在收听的是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯，又回来陪大家一周，顺便教训一下你们。开个玩笑。我又回来做一周关于美国日常故事的记录，运用各种广播叙事手法——纪录片、独白、偶然听到的对话、现成的磁带，任何我们能想到的手段。
And to consider the question of what it's like to be a teenager in America today, consider this incident between Kara and Jeremy and their friends. They had just come outside after a rehearsal for a school play that Kara is putting together based on the writings of Henry Rollins. And if you don't know his work, Henry Rollins is a pop star. He plays this sort of testosterone-loaded post-punk rock. And at the time of this recording, he was Kara's favorite writer.
为了探讨“当今美国的少女生活是什么样”这个问题，不妨看看卡拉、杰里米和他们的朋友们之间发生的这件小事。他们刚从学校话剧排练现场出来，卡拉正在编排这部剧，剧本基于亨利·罗林斯的文章。如果你不了解他的作品，亨利·罗林斯是一位流行歌星。他玩的是那种荷尔蒙爆棚的后朋克摇滚。在那次录音时，他是卡拉最喜欢的作家。
So, Kara, do you have a favorite piece in the Rollins show?
那么，卡拉，你在罗林斯的演出中最喜欢哪一段？
"Ladies, you want equality."
“女士们，你们想要平等。”
She pulls out the papers that comprise the show's script, and she reads to me. And I should say here that Rollins and our 18-year-old teenager get rather graphic here in a way that might not be suitable for younger listeners. Rollins, in this poem, says that guys are basically scum. Basically just scum. His vision is very unambiguous. They're scum. And he gives heartfelt advice to all women who he addresses as "ladies."
她拿出构成演出剧本的纸张，读给我听。我得说，罗林斯和我们这位18岁的少女在这里谈论的内容相当露骨，可能不太适合年纪较小的听众。罗林斯在这首诗中说，男人基本上就是人渣。简直就是人渣。他的观点非常明确。他们就是人渣。他给所有女性——他称之为“女士们”——提出了衷心的建议。
"If you want equality to men, it's not going to come to you in the mail or in your sleep. You're going to have to take it, grab hold of it, wrench it out of their hairy-fisted grasp. What I'm getting to is this-- go to the gunsmiths, get a 0.357 magnum with a long barrel. Load it. Put in your bag. Go on with your life.
“如果你想要与男性平等的权利，它不会通过邮件寄给你，也不会在你睡梦中到来。你必须去争取，紧紧抓住它，从他们那双长满老茧的手中夺过来。我要说的是——去枪械店，买一把长枪管的0.357麦格农手枪。装上子弹。放进包里。继续过你的生活。
OK, it's just another day. You're walking down the street. You pass this gas station. Some gas station attendant is standing there, glaring at you, checking you out, smiling at you. This ugly, greasy, stupid guy comes over to you and blocks your way as you try to walk down the street. He breathes on you and says, hey, baby, looky here, seven inches. You pull out the gun, stick the barrel in his face, and scream, I've got eight mother [BLEEP], I've got eight.
好了，这只是平常的一天。你走在街上。经过一个加油站。有个加油站员工站在那儿，盯着你看，打量你，对你笑。这个又丑又油腻的蠢货走过来，在你试图过马路时挡住你的去路。他对着你呼气，说，嘿，宝贝，看看这儿，有七英寸。你掏出枪，把枪管顶在他脸上，尖叫道，老娘有八英寸，你这（哔）养的，我有八英寸。
There. Now you're speaking in terms he can must surely identify with. You're not only equal. You dominate. Believe me, it's come to this. Take advantage of their weakness. They take advantage of yours. You're entitled."
瞧，现在你用的语言他绝对能听懂。你不仅平等了，而且你占了上风。相信我，事情已经到了这一步。利用他们的软弱。他们也在利用你的。这是你应得的。”
The guys in the group all look at each other. Finally, Kara's boyfriend, Jeremy, says, "There's nothing wrong with a guy looking at you and thinking how good you look." Kara tells him that isn't the point.
小组里的男生们面面相觑。最后，卡拉的男朋友杰里米说：“男生看你一眼，觉得你好看，这没什么错。”卡拉告诉他，重点不在这里。
No. They say things. They'll follow you. They'll come up to you, and they'll talk to you like this. And they'll make sure that they do that, that their pelvis is pushing against you here.
不。他们会说些话。他们会跟踪你。他们会靠近你，然后像这样跟你搭话。而且他们会确保这样做，确保他们的骨盆像这样贴着你。
I have never, ever seen anybody do that, though.
但我从来没见过有人那么做。
But you're not a woman, though.
但你又不是女人。
Kara tells him a story about some guy who was staring at her in a pool hall.
卡拉给他讲了一个故事，说有个男的在台球厅一直盯着她看。
So when I was leaving, he went-- he came up real close to me. He's like, "Bye." I turned around, and I was like, "I hate rude men!" I screamed it, and then the entire pool hall was like-- and I was like--
我离开的时候，他走过来——他靠得很近。他说：“再见。”我转过身，我说：“我讨厌无礼的男人！”我大叫起来，然后整个台球厅都……我就像……
Man. You guys are rough. I'm never saying bye to a girl again in my life.
天呐。你们太粗暴了。我这辈子再也不跟女生说再见了。
Mary's boyfriend, Aaron, has joined the conversation. "So how should we treat girls?" He asks. "If we like a girl, how do we let her know without offending her?"
玛丽的男朋友亚伦加入了谈话。“那么我们该如何对待女生呢？”他问。“如果我们喜欢一个女生，该怎么让她知道而不冒犯她？”
Right. That's why I'm asking how should we do it. And sometimes we don't know. And sometimes we don't know.
对啊。所以我才问我们该怎么做。有时候我们不知道。有时候真的不知道。
Don't look at women like they're pieces of meat. Because they're not.
不要把女性看作是某种肉块。因为她们不是。
But what if they're dressed like that and want to be looked at like that? There's always that instinct in the guy. And if he sees something he really likes, he's going to look at it. If you would see a guy that you really like and really think is hot, you don't sit here--
但如果她们穿成那样，想被那样看呢？男人总是有这种本能。如果他看到自己真正喜欢的东西，他就会去看。如果你看到一个你非常喜欢、觉得很火辣的男生，你不会坐在这儿——
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
（众声喧哗）
Wait, wait, wait. Listen to me. Listen to me. Listen to me. One, two, microphone check. Wait, listen. You're going to say, if a guy walks by that has a real nice butt that you like, you're not going to be like, damn.
等等，等等，等等。听我说。听我说。听我说。一、二，麦克风测试。等等，听着。你会说，如果有个屁股很翘的男生路过，是你喜欢的类型，你难道不会心想，哇塞。
They talk about this for 20 minutes. The boys ask over and over, what should we do? What do you want us to do? How should we act? And over and over, the girls name a few simple rules that anyone could follow if they pay attention. One, do not invade a girl's personal space. Two, don't say anything rude. Aaron says that certain things are only seen as rude if the girl doesn't like you. If she thinks you're cute, then they're OK.
他们谈论这个话题足足20分钟。男生们一遍又一遍地问，我们该怎么做？你希望我们怎么做？我们该表现得如何？女生们一遍又一遍地说出一些简单的规则，只要稍加注意，任何人都能做到。第一，不要侵犯女生的私人空间。第二，不要说无礼的话。亚伦说，有些事情只有在女生不喜欢你的时候才会被视为无礼。如果她觉得你很帅，那这些行为就没问题。
Say if I was real-- if I was good looking, and I was sitting there staring at you, and if I was all--
比如如果我很……如果我长得帅，我坐在那里盯着你看，如果我一直……
But I don't want to talk to a dork.
但我不想跟傻瓜说话。
But how does he know that? If I was a dork, maybe I think I'm looking. What if we're just at the staring stage?
但他怎么知道呢？如果我是个傻瓜，也许我以为我在看。如果我们只是处于盯着看的阶段呢？
No, no. Because if you don't know somebody, you've got to go by their--
不，不。因为如果你不认识某人，你必须通过他们的……
What's striking is that there are certain moments when it actually seems like the boys really do want to know how they should act. They really want to know. And in those moments it's clear that this conversation could only happen in high school. After high school, everyone's opinion about these questions is pretty much set. But in high school, sometimes there's still a feeling that everything's up for grabs. So you can tell your boyfriend not to be a jerk, and he might actually listen.
引人注目的是，在某些时刻，男生们似乎真的想知道他们该如何表现。他们真的很想知道。在这些时刻，很明显，这种对话只能发生在高中。高中之后，每个人对这些问题的看法基本定型了。但在高中，有时仍有一种感觉，一切皆有可能。所以你可以告诉你的男朋友不要做个混蛋，而他真的可能会听进去。
That's a good side of everything being up for grabs. There's also a bad side. With everything up for grabs, it's hard to know how you're supposed to act. Which brings us to today's program.
一切皆有可能的一面是好的。也有坏的一面。当一切皆有可能时，很难知道自己该如何行事。这就引出了今天的节目。
Our program today is made up of three stories about teenage girls who have to decide how they're going to act in situations where the ground rules are unclear and very malleable. Act One of our program, Jo Carol Pierce bends the rules in a small town in Texas.
我们今天的节目由三个关于少女的故事组成，她们必须决定在基本规则不明确且非常多变的情况下，自己该如何行事。节目的第一幕，乔·卡罗尔·皮尔斯在德克萨斯州的一个小镇上打破了规则。
Act Two, Chicago writer Rennie Sparks struggles without rules in suburban America, somewhere.
第二幕，芝加哥作家蕾妮·斯帕克斯在美国某个郊区，在没有规则的情况下挣扎。
Act Three, a man tries to lay down rules for a girl. Stay with us.
第三幕，一个男人试图为一个女孩定下规矩。请继续收听。
Act One, Texas Girl.
第一幕，德克萨斯女孩。
Jo Carol Pierce is this performer from Austin, Texas, who just put out her first album at the age of 51, squarely outside of the teenager category. But she talks about her teenage years in the record. And she's working this really unusual style on this record. The CD is called Bad Girls Upset By the Truth. I have it here.
乔·卡罗尔·皮尔斯是来自德克萨斯州奥斯汀的一位表演者，她在51岁时才发行了自己的第一张专辑，显然已经脱离了青少年的范畴。但她在唱片中谈到了自己的少女时代。她在唱片中运用了一种非常独特的风格。这张CD叫《被真相困扰的坏女孩》。我这里就有。
And over the course of the record, she tells this funny, emotional story punctuated periodically by songs she's written. It's a version of American musical theater, one of the most American cultural forms. It's a kind of American musical theater that no one is bothering with, except for her. And it's the kind of CD that is not going to get much radio air play anywhere, and so we thought that we would begin today's show by playing you just a chunk of this record, a couple songs and some of the story.
在整张唱片中，她讲述了一个有趣、感人的故事，中间不时穿插着她创作的歌曲。这是一种美国音乐剧，是美国文化中最具代表性的形式之一。这是一种除了她之外没人愿意尝试的美国音乐剧。这张CD很难在任何地方获得电台播放，所以我们想在今天的节目开头，为大家播放其中的一部分，包括几首歌和一些故事片段。
And the story that she tells on the record begins with a suicide attempt, a teenager's suicide attempt. In real life, Jo Carol says that she thought about suicide well into her 30s, and she also worked at a suicide hotline. And the suicide on the record comes during a fight with her boyfriend.
她在唱片中讲述的故事始于一次自杀未遂，一个少女的自杀未遂。在现实生活中，乔·卡罗尔说她直到30多岁还想过自杀，她还曾在自杀干预热线工作过。而在唱片里，自杀发生在一次与男友的争吵中。
Me and my boyfriend were driving around the loop, and we were having a terrible fight. I remember that he called me a son of a bitch. And that confused me, so I opened the passenger door and flung myself into traffic. First, I was hit by a pink Coupe de Ville, knocked me into the path of an out of state semi and just squished me flat into that burning asphalt.
我和男友开着车在环路上兜风，我们正在进行一场可怕的争吵。我记得他骂我是个婊子养的。这让我很困惑，所以我打开副驾驶车门，把自己甩进了车流中。首先，我被一辆粉色的凯迪拉克撞了，把我撞向一辆外州的大货车路径上，直接把我压扁在那燃烧的沥青路上。
But after I had committed suicide, I started seeing things in a whole new light. I noticed what a cute boy my boyfriend was. Couldn't understand why I'd been calling him a decorated rat only moments before my fatal plunge. I took his hand. It was chaffed and slightly smaller than mine. We went home, and I made him some biscuits and gravy from scratch, because I really wanted to.
但在我自杀之后，我开始以全新的视角看世界。我注意到我的男朋友是多么可爱的男孩。我不明白为什么在我致命的一跳前几分钟，我竟然一直叫他装点门面的老鼠。我牵起他的手。他的手有些磨损，比我的稍微小一点。我们回家了，我亲手为他做了饼干和肉汁，因为我真心想这么做。
It's good to commit suicide when there's something you just can't figure out. Like when I hit high school and I found out you're a bitch if you don't and a whore if you do. Commit suicide when you've got a burning question that no one can answer for you. Mine was, what are these boys for, and what am I supposed to do with them? Don't get upset about the war in the Middle East. Do something. Kill yourself.
当你遇到无法理解的事情时，自杀是个好主意。比如当我上高中时，我发现如果你不那么做，你就是个婊子，如果你做了，你就是个荡妇。当你有一个没人能回答的尖锐问题时，就去自杀吧。我的问题是，这些男生是为了什么，我该拿他们怎么办？不要为中东的战争感到难过。做点什么吧。去自杀吧。
It's good to commit suicide over small things that other people might neglect, like grocery shopping. I can't imagine walking into that ATB without first committing suicide. Think about it. Commit suicide first thing in the morning. And that way, you feel better all day. Do it your first day on a new job, and the next day you can call in dead. Do it early in a love affair and just get it over with.
为了那些其他人可能会忽视的小事而自杀是个好选择，比如去杂货店购物。我无法想象在不先自杀的情况下走进那家ATB超市。想一想。每天早上第一件事就是自杀。这样，你一整天都会感觉好一点。第一天上班时做一次，第二天你就可以打电话说你死了。在恋情开始时做一次，直接了当。
That's why me and the boys are going to commit suicide right now. We hope that you will join us. Just start getting really pitiful and morose, and in the third verse, we will slit our wrists.
这就是为什么我和男生们现在要一起自杀。希望你们能加入我们。开始变得可怜巴巴、闷闷不乐，在第三段歌词时，我们会割开手腕。
[MUSIC - BY JO CAROL PIERCE AND BAND]
（音乐 - 乔·卡罗尔·皮尔斯及乐队）
The main story of Bad Girls Upset By the Truth is this man, or this series of men, actually, who appear in Jo Carol's life. She calls them Secret Dans. And she falls for them, sleeps with them, and it's a lot of them. More, in fact, than anyone around her thinks is proper.
《被真相困扰的坏女孩》的主线故事是关于一个男人，或者说是一系列男人，他们出现在乔·卡罗尔的生活中。她称他们为“秘密丹”。她爱上了他们，与他们上床，而且人数很多。事实上，比她周围任何人认为的都要多。
I got in a world of trouble going from Secret Dan to Secret Dan. I got a bad reputation in my peer group. Lots of my friends were getting married, and when they did, they would just drop me flat. And my friends that weren't real mad at me were real worried about me. And everybody was discouraging me from falling in love. They said, Jo Carol, why don't you do something you're good at?
我在从一个“秘密丹”转向另一个“秘密丹”的过程中遇到了无穷无尽的麻烦。我在同龄人中名声扫地。我的很多朋友都结婚了，当她们结婚时，就会直接抛弃我。而那些没对我非常生气的也是真心为我担忧。每个人都在劝我不要坠入爱河。她们说，乔·卡罗尔，为什么不做点你擅长的事呢？
So I tried to explain to them why I had to do these very upsetting things. I said, look, the reason that I cannot pass up a single Secret Dan is that each one of them is just another side of Jesus. And I know that because every time I kiss another one, I can feel Jesus right through his skin. And I need to know Jesus fully. Jesus in a brown leather jacket. Or the kind of thuggy Jesus with the hooded eyes like Robert Mitchum. Or the Jesus you want to make biscuits for. Or the Jesus you want to wrestle with. Or the Catholic Jesus. Or the Jesus who's so good in bed you think he's Catholic, but really he's not. There was even a Yankee Jesus.
所以我试着向她们解释我为什么必须做这些令人沮丧的事情。我说，看，我无法拒绝任何一个“秘密丹”的原因是，他们每一个人都只是耶稣的另一面。我知道这一点，因为每次我亲吻另一个人时，我都能透过他的皮肤感受到耶稣。我需要完全了解耶稣。穿着棕色皮夹克的耶稣。或者那种带着像罗伯特·米彻姆那样兜帽眼睛的强盗耶稣。或者是你想为他做饼干的耶稣。或者是你想和他摔跤的耶稣。或者是天主教徒的耶稣。或者是床上功夫好到让你以为他是天主教徒，但实际上他不是的耶稣。甚至还有一个洋基耶稣。
And my friends said, nuh-uh. But I could tell my friends were upset by the truth, because they'd go off in small groups and whisper. And every once in a while I would hear this phrase, "mental hospital." And it made me nervous, so I got married. And when my husband slipped that golden wedding ring on my finger, it was the first time I'd ever strayed off of that spiritual path that Jesus had set out for me so specifically years before.
朋友们说，不行。但我看得出来，朋友们被真相困扰了，因为她们会聚成小群窃窃私语。偶尔我会听到“精神病院”这个词。这让我很紧张，所以我结婚了。当我的丈夫把那枚金戒指套在我的手指上时，那是我第一次偏离了耶稣多年前为我设定的那个精神道路。
It was back in high school. One sunny night I was out jumping bar ditches in my parents' car when it overheated and stalled and left me stranded out there on the Idalou highway. I didn't know what I was going to do until this darling boy named Joey came along in his shiny truck, and he fixed my car on the spot. And then he witnessed to me about Jesus. It was his Highway Witness for Jesus Program.
那是在高中。一个阳光明媚的夜晚，我开着父母的车在田间小路上颠簸，车子过热熄火，把我困在了伊达卢高速公路上。我不知道该怎么办，直到这个叫乔伊的可爱男孩开着闪亮的卡车经过，他当场修好了我的车。然后，他向我传达了耶稣的福音。那是他的“公路见证耶稣计划”。
And he was so darling that I just went to church with him that night. I liked sitting next to him so much, and before I knew what I was doing, I had grabbed his hand. He jerked and turned pale, but he did not get up and move. His heart was beating just like a hammer in the palm of his hand, and it was pounding home the sermon about the burning bush and the tongues of flame like never before. And I knew I had to keep that beat forever and ever.
他太可爱了，那天晚上我就跟他去了教堂。我非常喜欢坐在他旁边，还没等我反应过来，我就抓住了他的手。他猛地一缩，脸色苍白，但他没有站起来离开。他的心脏在他手心里像锤子一样跳动，那跳动声仿佛在重申那篇关于燃烧的灌木和火焰的舌头的布道，从未如此强烈。我知道我必须永远守住那份节奏。
And then we watched the preacher baptize Naomi [? Stutler. ?] And maybe it was the way her back arched when he pulled her up out of the water, or maybe it was the way that white robe clung to her body that inspired me to the point that I knew Jesus in my heart for the very first time, because he said something right in my ear. He said, "Don't you ever even worry about keeping that beat. You just let that beat keep you." I pretty much knew what was going to happen with the boys if I let that beat keep me, and I wasn't all that surprised that Jesus wanted me to go all the way. Because, after all, he did.
然后我们看着传教士为娜奥米受洗。也许是她从水中被拉出来时背部弯曲的样子，或者是那件白袍贴在她身上的样子，激励了我，让我第一次在心里感受到了耶稣，因为他就在我耳边说了一些话。他说：“别担心守住那节奏。你只要让那节奏守住你就好。”我基本知道如果让那节奏守住我，我和男生之间会发生什么，对于耶稣想要我彻底奉献，我并不感到惊讶。因为毕竟，他也曾那样做过。
I took my first step on my new spiritual path that evening after church when I suggested to Joey that we park at a prairie dog camp and discuss Jesus a little further. Later on, Joey was real disappointed in himself for what happened out there, but I wasn't. My new spiritual path was just like walking on cloud nine.
那天晚上教堂礼拜后，我迈出了新精神道路的第一步，当时我建议乔伊把车停在草原犬营地，更深入地讨论耶稣。后来，乔伊对自己在那儿发生的事情感到非常失望，但我没有。我的新精神道路就像走在云端一样。
I didn't hear from Joey for quite a while, but I didn't think anything about it. Because I had asked my question, what are these boys for, and what am I supposed to do with them in the plural. And it had been answered in the plural. And so I was real busy. But one evening Joey threw pebbles at my window, and I sneaked out behind the playhouse to meet him. And I found out why I had not heard from him was he had been saving up to buy me something very special.
我有很长一段时间没再见到乔伊，但我没多想。因为我提出了我的问题，这些男生是为了什么，而我该拿他们这些复数的人怎么办？答案已经以复数形式给出了。所以我很忙。但有一天晚上，乔伊往我窗户扔石子，我偷偷溜到凉亭后面去见他。我发现之所以一直没收到他的消息，是因为他一直在存钱想给我买件非常特别的礼物。
But unfortunately, the day he got it out of layaway was the very--
但不幸的是，他从代购店取回礼物的日子正好是……
Jo Carol, I heard you drove through the [? Hidey-Ho ?] take-out window naked today after school.
乔·卡罗尔，我听说你今天放学后裸体开车经过了“海迪霍”外卖窗口。
Oh god, I am so relieved. I was afraid I had made that whole thing up in my head and was turning out to be crazy like Mama. Because, see, what happened was I drove up, Buddy [? Grays ?] gives me my change and my chili dog. And I just sit there waiting for something to happen. And finally I say, "Buddy." He says, "What?" He says, "Hi." He says, "Hi." And I drove off feeling like I wasn't even in this world. I am so relieved somebody besides me thinks that happened.
哦天呐，我真是太如释重负了。我一直担心那整件事是我脑子里编造出来的，担心我会变得像妈妈一样疯狂。你看，事情是这样的，我开车过去，巴迪给了我找零和热狗。我坐在那儿等着事情发生。最后我说，“巴迪。”他说，“什么？”他说，“嗨。”他说，“嗨。”我就开车走了，感觉自己好像根本不在这个世界上。有人除了我之外也觉得那件事发生了，我真是太如释重负了。
How could you do this to me, Jo Carol?
你怎么能这样对我，乔·卡罗尔？
Well, sometimes I get real bored.
好吧，有时候我真的很无聊。
Well, if you're bored, there's plenty of constructive things you could do. You could raise a sheep or some chickens for the FFA. Or join the UFO Watch or go with me on the Highway Witness Program.
好吧，如果你无聊，有很多有建设性的事情可以做。你可以养只羊或者几只鸡参加FFA。或者加入UFO观察队，或者和我一起参加“公路见证计划”。
Now, wait, Joey. What did I ever do to you?
等等，乔伊。我到底对你做了什么？
You went out with Gary [? Cooney ?] tonight.
你今晚跟加里·库尼出去了。
Yeah?
是吗？
After he took Martha Lynn [? Searsey ?] home?
在他送玛莎·琳·瑟西回家之后？
Yeah?
是吗？
You ruined my life in my senior year.
你在我的高三毁了我的生活。
Oh, Joey, I am just sick I ruined your senior year. But how did I do it exactly?
哦，乔伊，我很难过我毁了你的高三。但我到底是怎样毁了它的？
I worked all my spare time to buy you this ring.
我所有的业余时间都在打工，就为了给你买这枚戒指。
Oh, Joey, that is so pretty. Bless your heart, it really is.
哦，乔伊，这真漂亮。保佑你的心，它真的很美。
It was my college education.
这是我的大学学费。
Look how it sparkles almost like a genuine diamond. If I wore this, people might think it was really real.
你看它闪闪发光，几乎就像一颗真正的钻石。如果我戴上它，人们可能会以为它是真的。
And that's when he took it from me. And he pulled it across the glass of the playhouse window, leaving a very deep scratch there.
就在那时，他从我手中夺过了戒指。他把它划过凉亭的玻璃窗，留下了一道很深的划痕。
[SINGING] This diamond is really real, Joey.
（演唱）这颗钻石是真的，乔伊。
[SINGING] Do you think I'd buy you a rhinestone?
（演唱）你以为我会给你买个人造水钻吗？
[SINGING] Do you really wanna marry me?
（演唱）你真的想娶我吗？
No. [SINGING] I just wanna go on home.
不。（演唱）我只是想回家。
[SINGING] Oh, Joey, how did it come to this? I'm so depressed.
（演唱）哦，乔伊，怎么会变成这样？我太沮丧了。
Well, Jo Carol, why do you think they even call it premarital sex? What are you going to call it if you don't get married afterwards?
那么，乔·卡罗尔，你觉得他们为什么叫它婚前性行为呢？如果你婚后没有在一起，你打算管它叫什么？
Oh, you could call it a whole lot of things. Like if you're trying to be--
哦，你可以叫它很多名字。比如如果你想——
Oh, I don't want to hear.
哦，我不想听。
[SINGING] I should have gone the way I came, like a flicker in her flame. Left her there remembering how my diamond scratched her window pane. Should have gone the way I came, in the darkness, in the rain. In the morning all that would remain is my scratch upon her window pane.
[歌唱] 我本该原路返回，就像她火焰中的一缕闪光。把她留在那里，回忆着我的钻石是如何划伤她的窗玻璃。我本该原路返回，在那黑暗中，在那雨中。清晨留下的只有我的划痕在她的窗玻璃上。
[SINGING] I'm so flattered, I can't tell you. But Jesus has another plan for me. And, Joey, it'll be better for you, too. Some day you're gonna thank me for all the girls you would have missed and never kissed if I said yes.
[歌唱] 我受宠若惊，无法言表。但上帝对我另有安排。而且，乔伊，这对你也好。总有一天，你会感谢我，因为如果我答应了，你就会错过那些你本该遇到却从未亲吻过的女孩。
Jo Carol, you're only worried about all the boys you want to kiss and mess around with.
乔·卡罗尔，你只担心那些你想亲吻和鬼混的男孩。
Well, that too, yes.
嗯，那也是，没错。
[SINGING] I should have gone the way I came, like a flicker in her flame, and left her there remembering how my diamond scratched her window pane. Should have gone the way I came, in the darkness in the rain, in the morning all that would remain is my scratch upon her window pane.
[歌唱] 我本该原路返回，就像她火焰中的一缕闪光，把她留在那里，回忆着我的钻石是如何划伤她的窗玻璃。我本该原路返回，在那黑暗中，在那雨中，清晨留下的只有我的划痕在她的窗玻璃上。
[SINGING] So it really has to be goodbye?
[歌唱] 所以真的非要说再见吗？
[SINGING] I don't know what else I could do.
[歌唱] 我不知道还能做什么。
[SINGING] One more time to remember me by?
[歌唱] 再来一次，好让你记住我？
Don't worry. [SINGING] I'll remember you.
别担心。[歌唱] 我会记住你的。
[SINGING] One more time so I'll remember, too.
[歌唱] 再来一次，这样我也能记住。
No. I don't want to.
不，我不想。
Joey, do you take me for a fool? I know you do.
乔伊，你当我是傻瓜吗？我知道你是这么想的。
Oh, god, she knows I do. And I do.
哦，天哪，她知道我是。而且我确实是。
[SINGING] I should have gone the way I came, like a flicker in her flame, and left her there remembering how my diamond scratched her window pane. Should've gone the way I came, in the darkness, in the rain. In the morning all that would remain is my scratch upon her window pane.
[歌唱] 我本该原路返回，就像她火焰中的一缕闪光，把她留在那里，回忆着我的钻石是如何划伤她的窗玻璃。我本该原路返回，在那黑暗中，在那雨中。清晨留下的只有我的划痕在她的窗玻璃上。
Jo Carol, if you keep on like this, who will every marry you?
乔·卡罗尔，如果你继续这样，将来谁会娶你？
Act Two, Suburban Girl.
第二幕，郊区女孩。
Well, you're listening to This American Life, where each week we take a theme and invite a variety of writers and performers and artists of various sorts to tackle the theme. This week our theme is teenage girls. And our next story is by Rennie Sparks, a Chicago writer and musician. Her band, The Handsome Family, does the musical scoring under the story.
欢迎收听《美国生活》，我们每周会选定一个主题，邀请各类作家、表演者和艺术家来探讨。本周的主题是“十几岁的女孩”。下一篇故事来自雷妮·斯帕克斯，一位芝加哥作家兼音乐人。她的乐队“英俊家庭”将为这则故事配乐。
This story is about a girl who is struggling in a situation where some rules-- there was a friendship, how you act with your best friend-- those rules are strict and completely binding. But all the other rules in the girl's life are totally in the air. And in the world she's in, she actually never worries about whether she's being good. Instead, she has other worries.
这个故事讲的是一个女孩，她陷入了一种规则严苛且完全束缚人的境地——关于友谊，关于你如何对待最好的朋友。但她生活中其他所有的规则都完全是不确定的。在她所处的世界里，她从未担心过自己是否是个好女孩。相反，她有其他的烦恼。
Dawn and me eat scrambled eggs with tall glasses of tomato juice for dinner because we're on a diet. Dawn knows how to throw up, so she eats toast and butter, too. But my fingers go so far down my throat, and still nothing comes up. I'm a fat cow.
道恩和我晚餐吃炒鸡蛋，配上一大杯番茄汁，因为我们在节食。道恩知道怎么催吐，所以她还吃吐司和黄油。但我把手指伸进喉咙很深的地方，却什么也吐不出来。我真是头肥猪。
Dawn and me are best friends. I sleep over at her house now ever since my stepfather called me a pig for eating all his cocktail onions. I'm waiting for my mom to call and beg me to come back home, but it's been almost two weeks now. I'm wondering if maybe their phone is broken.
道恩是我最好的朋友。自从继父因为我吃光了他的鸡尾酒洋葱而骂我是猪之后，我就一直住在她家。我在等我妈打电话求我回家，但已经快两周了。我在想，也许她们家的电话坏了。
Sometimes my mom spaces on time. She drinks a lot of green Hi-C with vodka in it. I've seen her sit down with a drink in the morning just as Oprah is coming on, and then it's like next thing she knows, Hard Copy is coming on and my stepdad is walking in the door, screaming because he can't smell any dinner.
有时我妈对时间很没概念。她喝很多加了伏特加的绿色Hi-C果汁。我见过她早上刚坐下喝一杯，正好赶上奥普拉的节目，接着就像是一转眼的功夫，《硬拷贝》节目就开始了，我继父走进来大喊大叫，因为他闻不到任何晚餐的味道。
But I'm over at Dawn's house now. We share a single bed with the quilted pink covers. We stay up late smoking cigarettes, talking about love with the ashtray balanced between us on the sheets. Dawn loves guys who give long, wet kisses that make her eyes roll up in her head. I love bites that last like red splashes on my neck for weeks, so that everyone knows I've been going at it. Dawn and me both agree, though-- mostly, we just want to fall in love. Tonight we're going to the mall to fall in love.
但我现在住在道恩家。我们共用一张铺着粉色绗缝被的单人床。我们熬夜抽烟，谈论爱情，烟灰缸就平衡地放在我们中间的床单上。道恩喜欢那些深吻得让她翻白眼的男人。我喜欢像红色斑点一样在脖子上持续好几周的吻痕，好让每个人都知道我一直在做那种事。不过，道恩和我达成共识——我们大体上只是想坠入爱河。今晚我们要去商场寻找爱情。
Dawn's mom is divorced, and Dawn gets to call her Lorraine instead of Mom. We smoke Lorraine's Marlboro Lights at the kitchen table with a green ashtray. Lorraine is in the shower with her loofah pad and her pineapple-smelling shampoo, getting ready to go out with an optometrist she met at work.
道恩的妈妈离婚了，道恩可以直接叫她洛琳，而不是妈妈。我们在厨房的桌子上抽着洛琳的万宝路淡烟，旁边是一个绿色的烟灰缸。洛琳正在用沐浴球和菠萝味的洗发水淋浴，准备去和她在工作中认识的一位验光师约会。
Lorraine works behind the counter at the U-Haul center on Motor Parkway, and she gets to wear this tight, orange dress that says U-Haul on it. She meets a lot of men because of that dress, not to mention that any guy who gets divorced ends up at U-Haul sooner or later with a sad look on his face.
洛琳在汽车租赁中心柜台工作，她总是穿着那件紧身的橙色连衣裙，上面印着公司名。因为那件裙子，她认识了很多男人，更不用说任何离婚的男人迟早都会带着一脸愁容来到租车点。
Lorraine comes out of the shower and models new underwear for us. Her hair is slicked back, wet and shiny. The underwear is red lace, with a fishnet heart cut out in the center, so you can see Lorraine's hair down there. And it's sort of dirty blond, even though Lorraine's hair on top is jet black. There's a long, purple scar up Lorraine's stomach from where they pulled Dawn out, but Lorraine's stomach is flat and tight like a boy's. She must know how to throw up, too.
洛琳洗完澡出来，给我们展示她的新内衣。她的头发向后梳着，湿润而闪亮。那是一件红色蕾丝内衣，中间挖了一个网眼心形镂空，你可以看到洛琳下面的毛发。那是种肮脏的亚麻色，尽管洛琳头顶的头发是乌黑的。洛琳的肚子上有一道长长的紫色伤疤，那是生下道恩时留下的，但她的肚子像男孩子一样平坦紧致。她一定也知道怎么催吐。
"Ta-da," Lorraine says. "You look fox, Lorraine," Dawn says. "Yeah," I say. "No doubt."
“塔哒，”洛琳说。“你看上去真迷人，洛琳，”道恩说。“是啊，”我说。“毫无疑问。”
The optometrist pulls up in a Chrysler, a dark blue car with brown interior. I'm thinking, loser, but Lorraine runs out of the kitchen, shoving her earrings in, smoothing down a red satin dress she bought at Shoes and Things for $20. She's blushing and pursing her lips to smooth her lip stick down and breathing fast as she let's the optometrist inside.
那位验光师开着一辆克莱斯勒停在门口，那是一辆深蓝色、内饰为棕色的车。我在想，真是个失败者，但洛琳从厨房跑了出来，一边塞着耳环，一边抚平她在商店花20美元买的红色缎面连衣裙。她脸红了，噘起嘴唇抹匀口红，呼吸急促地让验光师进屋。
He looks bewildered, unprepared to be stepping into a woman's house.
他看起来很困惑，显然没准备好进入一个女人的家。
"Dawn," Lorraine says in her giggle voice that is saved for men only, "I'll be home late, or not at all." Dawn rolls her eyes. "Watch it now, young lady," "OK," Dawn mumbles. "I'll feed the fish."
“道恩，”洛琳用那种只对男人才有的娇滴滴的声音说，“我今晚会很晚才回来，或者干脆不回来了。”道恩翻了个白眼。“注意点，年轻女士。”“好吧，”道恩咕哝道。“我会喂鱼的。”
"OK, Lorraine," the optometrist says nervously." "Seafood OK?" Lorraine just giggles and takes his arm. They head out to the car and drive away, and I want to cry, thinking of that skanking old guy with his hands all over Lorraine's perfect, tight body. But then I remember Dawn and me are on our own now.
“好的，洛琳，”验光师紧张地说。“海鲜可以吗？”洛琳只是咯咯笑着挽起他的胳膊。他们走向汽车开走了，我真想哭，想到那个猥琐的老男人用他的脏手摸遍了洛琳完美紧致的身躯。但随后我想到，现在只剩下道恩和我了。
We sit down at the kitchen table and light cigarettes and drink half a glass each of Lorraine's pink Zinfandel wine, because more than that she notices. "Man," Dawn says, "I can't wait to get a place of my own. All I'm going to have in the fridge in pink Zinfandel and powdered doughnuts and 7-Up. Dawn loves powdered doughnuts because they're the easiest thing in the world to throw up.
我们坐在餐桌旁点上烟，每人喝了半杯洛琳的粉红仙粉黛葡萄酒，因为喝多了她会发现。“天呐，”道恩说，“我真等不及要搬出去住。我冰箱里只放粉红仙粉黛、粉末甜甜圈和七喜。”道恩喜欢粉末甜甜圈，因为那是世界上最容易吐出来的东西。
Tonight we're off to the mall to hunt for babes. Dawn says if she falls in love at the mall, she'll go out to the pit. "And leave me hanging by the fountain," I scream. "No," she says, plugging in her crimping iron. "There'll be a babe for you, too. We'll find two babes and fall in love and make them take us to the pit."
今晚我们要去商场钓凯子。道恩说如果她在商场坠入爱河，她就会去“坑”里。“那把我一个人丢在喷泉边，”我尖叫道。“不，”她说着插上了卷发棒的电源。“也会有你的菜的。我们会找到两个男人，坠入爱河，让他们带我们去坑里。”
Dawn's going to be a stewardess when she graduates high school, or work at the U-Haul with Lorraine. I'm going to Wilfred Beauty Academy to learn acrylic nails. When I get out of Wilfred, no one will call me a fat cow. They'll call me a nail stylist.
道恩高中毕业后想当空姐，或者和洛琳一起在租车中心工作。我打算去威尔弗雷德美容学校学习美甲。当我从学校毕业时，没人会再叫我肥猪。他们会叫我美甲师。
I have a new makeup stick in dark coral pink. I put it on above my eyes like I saw in Beauty Digest. Dawn puts it on her cheeks and outlines her lips in burnt sienna. She rubs a stick of musk behind her ears and under her arms, filling the room with the smell of a jungle.
我有一支新的深珊瑚粉色化妆笔。我按照《美容文摘》上的样子涂在眼皮上方。道恩把它涂在脸颊上，并用焦赭色勾勒唇线。她在耳后和腋下涂抹麝香，让房间里充满丛林的味道。
We lie flat on the bed next to each other to zip our jeans. When I stand up, there's a role of fat over the waistband, so I borrow a loose sweater from Dawn, something with draw strings at the bottom. Dawn is straight and thin and wears padded bras that make tiny puff breasts under her shirts. I wish I could throw up like her.
我们平躺在床上互相帮助拉上牛仔裤拉链。当我站起来时，腰间有一圈赘肉，所以我借了道恩的一件宽松毛衣，下摆带抽绳的那种。道恩又直又瘦，穿着带衬垫的胸罩，衬衫下显得胸部微微隆起。我真希望我也能像她一样呕吐。
We each swallow four of Lorraine's Dexatrims and two of her No-Dozs and then fluff our hair out so we look like wild animals. We only take one each of Lorraine's Valiums, because those she counts.
我们各自吞下了四片洛琳的减肥药和两片提神药，然后把头发抓蓬，看起来像野兽一样。我们每人只吃了一片洛琳的安定片，因为那个她会数数。
The cab lets us off at Sears. We go in through the luggage department and straight into the bathroom. Dawn doesn't like the way her hair turned out, so she wets it in the sink and kneels under the hand dryer, on knee on the tile floor to do it over. I look at myself in the mirror. My hair and nails are perfect. I know how to copy the looks. But my cheeks are full and red, not hollow and sharp like Dawn's. Tomorrow I'll eat nothing but tuna fish and water.
出租车把我们放在西尔斯百货。我们从行李区进去，直接去了洗手间。道恩不喜欢她发型的效果，所以她在水槽里打湿头发，跪在洗手间瓷砖地板上手持吹风机重新弄。我对着镜子看了看自己。我的头发和指甲都很完美。我知道怎么模仿那些造型。但我的脸颊圆润红润，不像道恩那样凹陷且轮廓分明。明天我除了金枪鱼和水，什么都不吃。
We walk out to the benches around the fountain and spot Carol and Gail. Even from two stores down, I can see Carol's lost weight, and I'm instantly jealous. She was always a pudge like me. Then she had to go to the clinic for an abortion, and she threw up for two days after the anesthetic. It makes me wonder why no one sells anesthetic to fat people for a diet. I guess it's against the law, but still it isn't fair.
我们走到喷泉周围的长椅上，看到了卡罗尔和盖尔。即使隔着两家店，我都能看出卡罗尔瘦了，我立刻感到嫉妒。她以前和我一样胖。后来她去诊所做了堕胎手术，麻醉后她吐了两天。这让我纳闷，为什么没有人把麻醉剂卖给胖子当减肥药。我想这是违法的，但还是不公平。
Two weeks before Carol went to the clinic, she said, "Janine, walk with me to the deli." So I walked with her to the deli and got a ham sandwich with only a little mayo and even pulled the crusts off and threw them away. Carol got change for the phone. She called the clinic and said she got raped and wanted the morning after pill. This wasn't true.
卡罗尔去诊所前两周曾说：“珍妮，陪我去熟食店。”所以我陪她去了，买了个火腿三明治，只放了很少的蛋黄酱，甚至把面包皮撕掉扔了。卡罗尔去换硬币打电话。她给诊所打电话说她被强奸了，想要事后避孕药。这不是真的。
Carol told me about the moment down in the pit when Scott Malone had finally got off her, and she had to squat and search for a full minute before she found the rubber. It didn't matter, anyway, because the clinic said she had to tell the police first if she got raped. So Carol hung up and fell against gallon jars of pickled cauliflower, crying her eyes out. But when I tried to put my arm around her, she said, "You smell like ham, Janine," and pushed me away. I don't care. Dawn is my best friend, anyway.
卡罗尔告诉我在坑里的那一刻，当斯科特·马龙终于从她身上下来时，她不得不蹲下来搜寻了整整一分钟才找到避孕套。反正也没用，因为诊所说如果她被强奸了，必须先告诉警察。于是卡罗尔挂了电话，瘫倒在一大罐腌花椰菜旁，哭得泣不成声。但当我试图搂住她时，她说：“你身上有火腿味，珍妮，”并把我推开了。我不在乎。反正道恩才是我最好的朋友。
Dawn and me and Carol and Gail are sitting in front of the fountain waiting for babes. Gail is beautiful and goes out with Joey Cosmo, who has a roll bar in his truck and wild blond hair like a rock star. But he's at some truck show in Garden City tonight, so Gail is a free agent.
道恩、我、卡罗尔和盖尔坐在喷泉前等男人。盖尔很漂亮，和乔伊·科斯莫约会，他的卡车里有防滚架，留着像摇滚明星一样的狂野金发。但他今晚在加登城的某个卡车展，所以盖尔是自由身。
I never told anyone, but I have a secret about Joey Cosmo. Once I walked by Sheer Impact, and I saw Joey sitting under a dryer with perm rods in his hair. It made we want him even more, seeing him with the plastic sheet over him, the white towel around his neck, and blue and yellow perm rods covering his head like a helmet. Any guy who thinks he ought to try and look good, even if he's a babe already, has got to be sort of sweet. I wouldn't cheat on him just because he went to a truck show without me, but I'm not beautiful like Gail, and the rules are different.
我从未告诉过任何人，但我有个关于乔伊·科斯莫的秘密。有一次我路过“纯粹冲击”发廊，看到乔伊坐在吹风机下，头发上卷着烫发卷。看到他披着塑料布，脖子上围着白毛巾，头上覆盖着蓝黄相间的烫发卷像个头盔一样，这让我更迷他了。任何一个想让自己看起来更帅的男人，哪怕他已经是个帅哥了，也一定很可爱。我不会因为他没带我去卡车展就背叛他，但我没有盖尔那么漂亮，规矩是不一样的。
Tonight Gail has done her eyes in blue liner. Her hair is soft blond that curls at her shoulder, and she's long and thin in pink cords and a black sweater that shows a beige bra under her arm when she lifts a hand to flip her hair back. It's hard to believe we're both girls. I've never come close to looking anything like her.
今晚盖尔画了蓝色眼线。她的头发是柔和的金色，卷在肩膀上，她穿着粉色灯芯绒裤子和黑色毛衣，高挑纤瘦。当她举手撩头发时，能看到胳膊下米色的胸罩。真难相信我们都是女孩。我从来没达到过她那种样子。
"What's up?" She says, throwing her cigarette into the fountain. There's a hiss as flame hits water. "Nothing," Dawn says. "How you feeling?" I ask Carol. She gives me a look. "I'm staying at Gail's." "Janine's staying at my house," Dawn says. "How come?" Gail asks, suddenly interested, thinking something's up like I'm pregnant or something. "My stepfather's a skank," I say quickly, feeling a moment's pride being the center of attention. "They're all skanks," Gail says. "My stepfather stole 10 bucks from my purse last week." Dawn's elbow sinks into my side. "Babes," she whispers. And there they are.
“怎么样？”她说，把烟头扔进喷泉。火苗碰到水发出嘶嘶声。“没怎样，”道恩说。“你感觉如何？”我问卡罗尔。她看了我一眼。“我住在盖尔家。”“珍妮住在我们家，”道恩说。“怎么了？”盖尔好奇地问，以为发生了什么事，比如我怀孕之类的。“我继父是个混蛋，”我脱口而出，因成为焦点而感到一丝自豪。“他们都是混蛋，”盖尔说。“我继父上周从我钱包里偷了10美元。”道恩的胳膊肘撞了撞我的侧腹。“男人，”她轻声说。他们就在那里。
Janine and Dawn make their move for the babes in a minute when our program continues.
节目继续，珍妮和道恩马上就要出击那些男人了。
It's This American Life. Rennie Sparks's story "Skanks" continues. A little reminder that some scenes and language in this story might not be suitable for younger listeners.
这是《美国生活》。雷妮·斯帕克斯的故事《混蛋》继续。友情提醒，故事中的某些场景和语言可能不适合年轻听众。
Dawn, Janine, and their friends, if you recall, are sitting on the bench by the fountain in the mall.
如果你还记得，道恩、珍妮和她们的朋友正坐在商场喷泉边的长椅上。
Three guys turning the corner from Monkey Ward's. We lean back with our toes stretched out in high heels. I can feel the water spray against my back, but I don't move. The waist of my jeans is like an iron band. I can hardly breathe.
三个男人从蒙哥马利沃德百货拐角走过来。我们向后仰，脚尖伸向高跟鞋前方。我能感觉到喷泉的水雾喷在背上，但我没动。牛仔裤腰像铁箍一样勒着我。我几乎喘不过气来。
Dawn stands. "Janine, let's go." "We just sat down," I say. "Look at that babe in the red leather," Dawn says. "He's checking me out." "Can't we just sit here a while?" I say. "Janine, do you want to be a fat cow all your life?" Dawn says. "The blond one isn't bad. He's got long hair. Let's go."
道恩站起来。“珍妮，我们走。”“我们才刚坐下，”我说。“看那个穿红皮衣的帅哥，”道恩说。“他在打量我。”“我们就不能在这儿坐一会儿吗？”我说。“珍妮，你难道想一辈子当头肥猪吗？”道恩说。“那个金发的也不错。他留着长发。走吧。”
We go after the babes. They strut around the corner of Camera Hut with long, pink combs sticking out of their back pockets. Dawn's right. I have to do something with my life.
我们去追那些男人。他们大摇大摆地绕过相机店拐角，后口袋插着长长的粉色梳子。道恩说得对。我必须做点什么来改变我的人生。
We follow them down the north corridor of the mall. I watch the babe in the red leather. His thin hips jut back and forth in tight black denims. I feel myself slow and heavy at Dawn's side.
我们沿着商场的北走廊跟踪他们。我看着那个穿红皮衣的帅哥。他纤细的臀部在紧身黑牛仔裤下左右摆动。我感到自己走在道恩身边显得又慢又笨重。
They go into Orange Julius, and Dawn clicks fast on high heels behind them. The two bomber jackets buy chili dogs, but the red leather buys fries. He turns as he squirts ketchup, and he has these unbelievable sea-green eyes. I feel a butterfly come alive in my stomach, and I could almost collapse with the feel of it coming over me. But I force myself to look at the blond one, like Dawn wants, even though he's ugly.
他们走进了奥兰治朱利叶斯饮料店，道恩穿着高跟鞋在后面快步跟上。那两个穿短夹克的人买了辣椒热狗，但红皮衣买了薯条。他挤番茄酱时转过身，有一双难以置信的海绿色眼睛。我感到胃里有蝴蝶在飞舞，那种感觉让我几乎要崩溃。但我强迫自己去看那个金发的，就像道恩想要的那样，尽管他很难看。
"What's up?" The babe asks, staring down at the floor. He smiles, and I see his teeth are white and clean like a commercial. He has dyed black hair with brown roots. "Nothing," Dawn says, moving in. I try and give the blond one a look, but he's worse close up. His hair is long but hangs flat against the sides of his face, and his body is round and square like Barney Rubble. I feel myself rolling loose, bursting against my jeans, and I can see from his face that I'm just as unappealing to him. I manage a weak smile.
“怎么样？”那个帅哥问，盯着地板。他微笑着，我看到他的牙齿像广告里一样洁白整洁。他染了黑发，但露出了棕色的发根。“没什么，”道恩说，凑了上去。我试着给那个金发的递个眼神，但他离近了看更糟糕。他的头发很长，但平贴在脸颊两侧，身材圆圆方方的，像巴尼·瓦砾。我感到自己身体松垮，牛仔裤都要被撑爆了，从他的脸上我能看出对他而言我也一样没什么吸引力。我勉强挤出一个尴尬的微笑。
They slide into a booth with their food, throwing fries at each other across the table. We order cheese fries and sit across from them. We suck cheese off the fries and then put them back on the plate, waiting. I suck only five fries. Dawn sucks down practically the whole plate. She can. She's already thrown up twice since breakfast.
他们滑进一个隔间吃东西，隔着桌子互相扔薯条。我们点了芝士薯条，坐在他们对面。我们吮吸着薯条上的芝士，然后把它们放回盘子里等着。我只吮吸了五根薯条。道恩几乎吸光了整盘。她做得到。因为从早餐后她已经吐过两次了。
Finally the babe finishes his food and looks across the table at Dawn. "Hey," the babe says. "Hey," Dawn says. "What's up?" he says. "Nothing," she says. "You want to hang out?" "Sure," she says. "I'm Dawn. This is Janine." "Hey," he says, looking my way for the briefest moment. He's a definite babe. Tall and thin with hollow cheeks and a square chin. "Listen," Dawn says, leaning in towards the babe. She gives a look-- perfect, all eyes and lips. "Janine was checking out your friend," she whispers. "The blond guy. She's in love with him or something." "That's Stevie," the babe says. "He's cool."
最后那个帅哥吃完东西，看着对面的道恩。“嘿，”那个帅哥说。“嘿，”道恩说。“怎么样？”他说。“没什么，”她说。“想一起玩吗？”“当然，”她说。“我是道恩。这是珍妮。”“嘿，”他说，看了我一眼，仅那一瞬间。他绝对是个帅哥。高瘦，两颊凹陷，下巴方正。“听着，”道恩说着，向那个帅哥靠过去。她递了个眼色——完美，全是眼睛和嘴唇。“珍妮刚才在看你朋友，”她悄悄说。“金发那个。她好像爱上他了。”“那是史蒂维，”帅哥说。“他很酷。”
The babe stands, pressing his hips into the edge of the table. Dawn's fingers stroke the tabletop. Her nails, hard pink shells, click against the tabletop. "Cool," she whispers. She stands, brushing against the babe as she pulls out of the booth. There's the sizzle of fabric against fabric. "We'll meet you by Macy's," she says, and struts fast out of Orange Julius, heading back towards the Sears bathroom. I follow, running to keep up.
帅哥站起来，把臀部顶在桌子边缘。道恩的手指抚摸着桌面。她那硬硬的粉色指甲在桌面上敲击着。“酷，”她低语道。她站起身，在走出隔间时蹭了一下那个帅哥。布料与布料之间发出了细微的摩擦声。“我们在梅西百货门口见，”她说，快步走出饮料店，向西尔斯百货的洗手间走去。我跑着跟上去。
In the bathroom I open my eyes as wide as possible, feeling tears building up at the edge of my mascara. "I can't believe you, Dawn." My voice is heavy and scratched. "Telling that guy I was hot for his skank friend." "He's all right," Dawn says, putting on lip gloss with a fingertip. "He has long hair. What's with you?" "I don't want to hang with him is all." I press my index fingers to the corner of my eyes. The tips of my fingers are black with mascara and tears. There's a noise at the back of my throat that wants to come out, but I know Dawn will be mad if I let it.
在洗手间里，我尽可能地睁大眼睛，感到睫毛膏边缘涌出了泪水。“真不敢相信你，道恩。”我的声音沉重而沙哑。“竟然告诉那个家伙我对他的混蛋朋友感兴趣。”“他还行，”道恩说着，用指尖涂抹唇彩。“他有长头发。你到底是怎么了？”“我只是不想和他一起玩。”我用食指按住眼角。我的指尖因睫毛膏和泪水而变黑了。喉咙深处有一种想发出的声音，但我知道如果我发出声，道恩会生气的。
My stomach feels huge. The thought of that skanky Barney Rubble out there makes me want to puke, though he's no worse than some of the others I've had to put up with. It's no coincidence that every babe Dawn finds has a skanky-looking best friend along with him. That's what people see when they look at Dawn and me. I've noticed how beautiful people like to have a skank friend to hang out with. It makes them look even better.
我的胃感觉大得吓人。想到外面那个混蛋巴尼·瓦砾就让我反胃，尽管他并不比我不得不应付的其他男人差。道恩找的每个帅哥都带着一个混蛋样子的死党，这绝非巧合。这就是人们在看我和道恩时看到的东西。我注意到漂亮的人喜欢找个混蛋朋友一起玩。这能让他们看起来更好。
"Oh, man," Dawn says. "Are you my best friend, or what?" "You know I am." My voice cracks in half. Carefully I wipe away the black tear running down my cheek with a twist of Kleenex. "I just don't want to be with that guy," I tell her. "He's a skank, and you know it."
“哦，天哪，”道恩说。“你到底是不是我最好的朋友？”“你知道是的。”我的声音哽咽了。我小心地用纸巾擦掉脸颊上那道黑色的泪痕。“我只是不想和那个家伙在一起，”我告诉她。“他是个混蛋，你心里清楚。”
A lady comes into the bathroom carrying a shopping bag. She goes into a stall. Dawn turns the hand dryer on so we can talk privately. "Look," Dawn whispers. "If you're my best friend, you'll do this for me. Because I'll tell you one thing for sure-- only my best friend can sleep over at my house tonight." I stand there weeping. It takes forever to get my breath.
一个拎着购物袋的女人走进洗手间。她走进隔间。道恩打开吹风机，这样我们就能私下交谈了。“听着，”道恩悄声说。“如果你是我最好的朋友，你会为我这么做的。因为我肯定告诉你一件事——今晚只有我最好的朋友能在我家过夜。”我站在那里哭泣。我花了很久才平复呼吸。
"Janine," Dawn says finally, tiring of my crap, "fix your face and let's go." I get out my compact and brush powder across my cheekbones, and then redo my mascara and eyeliner. I work quickly, knowing Dawn will leave me behind if I don't hurry.
“珍妮，”道恩终于厌倦了我的烂事，说道，“整理好你的脸，我们要走了。”我拿出粉盒在颧骨上扑粉，然后重新补了睫毛膏和眼线。我工作得很快，因为我知道如果我不赶快，道恩会丢下我离开。
A woman comes in with a little boy, chocolate ice cream smeared down his cheeks. She lifts him up to the sink and wets a tissue to wipe his face. I want to go away with her. I want to be a child again.
一个女人带着一个小男孩走进来，孩子脸颊上涂满了巧克力冰淇淋。她把他抱到水槽边，湿润纸巾擦他的脸。我真想跟着她一起走。我想重新变回孩子。
"Look," Dawn says, leaning into me, her voice softer now. "You don't have to do anything. I just don't want to be alone with the guy the first time. We'll stick together, I promise. And later when we get home, we'll eat some eggs or something. OK?"
“听着，”道恩靠近我，声音柔和了一些。“你什么都不用做。我只是不想第一次和他单独相处。我们会待在一起，我保证。等晚点回到家，我们吃点鸡蛋什么的。好吗？”
I nod my head. My face is glowing again in the mirror. I open my eyes wide, testing my mascara. A toilet flushes, and the woman with the shopping bag comes out, washes up, looks at herself in the mirror. She slides her lips together, evening out her lipstick. She's pretty for an old lady. She must be at least 40. It's depressing to think about all the years I'll have to worry about my makeup and my hair before I get old enough that no one cares.
我点了点头。我的脸在镜子里又焕发了光彩。我睁大眼睛，测试睫毛膏的情况。马桶冲水了，那个拎购物袋的女人走出来，洗了手，对着镜子审视自己。她抿了抿嘴唇，抹匀口红。对于一个老女人来说，她很漂亮。她一定至少40岁了。想到在老到没人关心之前，我还要为化妆和头发烦恼那么多年，真让人沮丧。
We leave the bathroom, head to Macy's, and there they are, waiting for us by the exit. The babe sees us and pulls a wig crooked on a mannequin to show off. I smile. My skin is tight with layers of powder, but underneath it I can feel my face swollen from crying.
我们离开洗手间，前往梅西百货，他们正等在出口处。那个帅哥看到我们，把假人模特头上的假发拽歪了以此炫耀。我笑了。我的皮肤因厚厚的粉底而紧绷，但在粉底之下，我能感觉到脸颊因哭泣而肿胀。
"Hey, what's up?" The babe says. "This is my buddy. Stevie. He's cool." "Hi," I say. I bend my lips up into something like a smile. Dawn is giggling with her hand over her mouth. "What's up?" Stevie says. His eyes are crooked and small.
“嘿，怎么样？”帅哥说。“这是我哥们，史蒂维。他很酷。”“嗨，”我说。我弯起嘴唇露出了一个类似微笑的表情。道恩捂着嘴咯咯地笑。“怎么样？”史蒂维说。他的眼睛斜斜的，很小。
We head out to the parking lot. It's dark out. Headlights reflect off cars as we walk out to the strip of grass that separates the highway from Macy's parking lot. Thick, green bushes are planted in a row that lead out to the entrance and exit signs that separate the lanes of traffic in and out of Macy's.
我们走向停车场。外面很黑。当我们走到将高速公路与梅西百货停车场隔开的草地边缘时，汽车大灯映照过来。茂密的绿色灌木丛排成一行，通向进出口标识，将进出梅西百货的车流分道。
Dawn and me lean against the enter sign. Stevie and the babe stand across from us. The babe has a pint of Southern Comfort. He passes it around. A wind is blowing, drying the sweat under my arms.
道恩和我倚在“入口”标识牌上。史蒂维和帅哥站在我们对面。帅哥有一品脱南方舒适威士忌。他传给每个人喝。风在吹，吹干了我腋下的汗水。
"So," the babe says, finally, "what's up?" "I'm cold," Dawn says. "Here," he says. He takes off his leather, wraps it around her, leaving his arm on her shoulder.
“那么，”帅哥最后说道，“最近怎么样？”“我冷，”道恩说。“给你，”他说。他脱下皮衣裹在她身上，手臂留在她肩上。
Suddenly they're going at it. She falls against the enter sign with a bang, and I move away quickly as he presses into her with his hips and chest. I look at Stevie and past him at the cars streaming by on the highway. He makes a noise in his throat and spits on the grass.
突然他们就纠缠在一起了。她撞在入口标识牌上发出“砰”的一声，当他用臀部和胸部压向她时，我迅速挪开了。我看着史蒂维，越过他看向高速公路上疾驰而过的汽车。他在喉咙里发出声音，往草地上吐了口唾沫。
"What's up?" he says. "Nothing," I say, looking down. He put his arm around me. The babe has a hand up Dawn's shirt. I catch a corner of her bra under his cupped hand. Stevie's hand curls around my shoulder slowly. I can tell he thinks I won't notice.
“怎么样？”他说。“没什么，”我低下头说。他搂住我的肩膀。那个帅哥的手伸进了道恩的衬衫。我在他合拢的手掌下抓住了她胸罩的一角。史蒂维的手慢慢绕过我的肩膀。我看得出他以为我不会注意到。
The babe breaks away from Dawn a moment and says, "time to hit the pit?" Dawn looks at me. "Come on, Janine." I shake my head. She puckers her lips. We go behind the exit sign. She's sweaty, her makeup rising like a film over her face. "Janine you want a place to sleep tonight?" Her voice is thick, breathless. It's dark enough out that I just let my mascara run with a flood of tears. I know Dawn can see, but she just flips her hair and steps back away from me, talking loud so the guys can hear.
那个帅哥从道恩身上分开了一会儿说：“该去‘坑’里了吗？”道恩看着我。“走吧，珍妮。”我摇摇头。她噘起嘴唇。我们走到出口标识牌后面。她全身是汗，化妆品像一层薄膜一样浮在脸上。“珍妮，你想今晚有个地方睡吗？”她的声音沙哑、喘不过气。外面足够黑，我任由睫毛膏随泪水流淌。我知道道恩看得见，但她只是甩了甩头发，从我身边走开，大声说话以便让那两个男人听到。
"You think you can do better?" she says. I look at her. Even in the wind from the cars and the sweat on her face, she's still something I'll never be. From the tiny points of her shoulders to the long swoop of her legs, down to her ankles, like glass balanced on high heels. I give in.
“你觉得你能找个更好的吗？”她说。我看着她。即使在疾驰而过的车风中，即使脸上带着汗水，她依然是我永远无法企及的样子。从她尖尖的小肩膀到修长的双腿，再到像高跟鞋上平衡的玻璃一样纤细的脚踝。我妥协了。
We cross the highway and take the path down to the woods we call the pit. It's just dug up land from where they took the dirt to make the cement for the mall a million years ago. Thin pine trees planted along the highway have grown tall to block out the streetlights, and below, sticker bushes divide the pit into narrow pathways and openings where people hang in the dark to fool around or do drugs or hide from the cops.
我们穿过高速公路，走上通往那片我们称之为“坑”的树林的小路。那不过是几百万年前为了挖掘商场混凝土所需泥土而挖出的土地。沿着高速公路种植的细长松树已经长高，挡住了路灯。在下方，刺丛将坑划分成狭窄的小径和开阔地，人们在黑暗中躲在那儿鬼混、吸毒或躲避警察。
Stevie has a hand on my ass. He whispers in my ear, "You got at nice body, OK?" The babe and Dawn have disappeared into the woods. I call her name, but she won't answer. From up the hill I hear a truck shifting gears, a horn. Some guy screams, "Dildo." Stevie says, "Shh, relax."
史蒂维的手放在我的屁股上。他在我耳边低语：“你的身材不错，对吧？”那个帅哥和道恩已经消失在树林里了。我喊她的名字，但她不回应。从坡上我听到卡车换挡的声音和喇叭声。有人尖叫道：“傻逼。”史蒂维说：“嘘，放松。”
We walk further into the pit, passing the dark outlines of couples against trees or rolling slowly in the dirt. We find a clearing with an overturned shopping cart, and Stevie sits. I go to sit next to him, but he grabs my head tight over my ears so that everything sounds like an ocean. And behind the roar I hear him whispering, "I love you. Yeah, I really love you, OK?" Pushing me down to my knees, pushing my face into his zipper. And then there's the smell of him, gagging me through his jeans.
我们向坑的更深处走去，路过一对对依偎在树边或在泥土中缓慢翻滚的黑影。我们找到了一个有废弃购物车的小空地，史蒂维坐下了。我走过去想挨着他坐，但他紧紧按住我的头，盖住我的耳朵，让我听到的所有声音都像大海。在轰鸣声背后，我听到他低语：“我爱你。是的，我真的爱你，好吗？”把我按跪在地上，把我的脸推向他的拉链。接着就是他身上那股味儿，透过牛仔裤让他窒息。
I've been in this position before, lots of times, because of Dawn and other girls who were once my best friend. And lots of times when I thought maybe a guy might really like me. I know I'm supposed to go numb, just open my mouth and let it happen, and then wait for Dawn to call me to go home.
因为道恩和其他曾是我最好朋友的女孩，这种姿势我已经经历过很多次了。还有很多次，当我以为也许某个男人真的可能会喜欢我时。我知道我应该麻木，只要张开嘴，让它发生，然后等待道恩叫我回家。
But this time I can't seem to. This time there's no pretending that I'm doing it for Dawn or for myself or for any reason at all. Because this time I can see suddenly that Dawn is getting tired of me. Even if I play this right with Stevie, my days are numbered as her best friend.
但这一次我似乎做不到了。这一次，我无法再假装我是为了道恩、为了自己，或者为了任何理由而这样做。因为这一刻我突然明白，道恩已经厌倦我了。就算我在这件事上处理得当，我和她做闺蜜的日子也屈指可数了。
I open my eyes. After a moment, the gold thread along the zipper of his jeans appears. Tears are running into my mouth. My M up is shot. I try. I try so hard for Dawn, for my best friend. I try to keep my face pressed against his zipper, but I can't. And when his hand comes down and unbuttons his jeans, I pull away and stand up.
我睁开眼睛。片刻之后，他牛仔裤拉链旁的金线映入眼帘。泪水涌入我的嘴里。我的妆全花了。我努力了。为了道恩，为了我最好的朋友，我真的尽力了。我试图让脸贴在他的拉链上，但我做不到。当他的手伸下来解开牛仔裤时，我退缩并站了起来。
"You're a skank," I hear myself say. "Hey," he says. "Come on, help me out here. You can't leave me like this. It's killing me, OK?"
“你这混蛋，”我听见自己说道。“嘿，”他说，“拜托，帮个忙。你不能就这样丢下我。这快把我折磨死了，行吗？”
I call for Dawn, but she still won't answer, so I turn and start back up toward the road. "Hey," Stevie yells after me. "You on the rag or something?" "I'm leaving, Dawn," I yell one last time. I know if I walk back to the mall, I'll be doing something awful. I know as soon as I step out of these woods, I won't have a best friend anymore.
我呼唤道恩，但她依然没有回应，于是我转过身，向着马路走去。“嘿，”史蒂维在我身后大喊，“你是不是来例假了，还是怎么着？”“我要走了，道恩，”我最后一次大喊。我知道如果我走回商场，我就要做出可怕的事了。我知道只要我走出这片树林，我就再也没有最好的朋友了。
"Oh, get lost, fat girl," Stevie yells from behind me. Then after a moment he adds, "It's your loss, OK?" I start to run. I run up out of the woods and across the highway and through the lines of parked cars and into Macy's. I run through lingerie and pantyhose and piles of scarves. I run to the center of the mall where I stop, with a burning cramp squeezing my side, feeling my fat stomach covered in sweat under Dawn's borrowed sweater. I stand there panting, my face aching with dried tears. No one seems to notice me.
“哦，滚远点吧，死肥婆，”史蒂维在我身后喊道。过了一会儿，他又补充说：“这是你的损失，懂吗？”我开始奔跑。我跑出树林，穿过高速公路，穿过停满车辆的行列，冲进了梅西百货。我跑过内衣区、丝袜区和围巾堆。我跑向商场中心并停了下来，侧腹处痉挛阵阵作痛，汗水浸透了套在道恩借给我的毛衣底下的肥胖身躯。我站在那里喘着粗气，脸上还带着干涸泪水的酸楚。似乎没人注意到我。
The benches by the fountain are empty, and something tells me if I've lost Dawn, I've lost Gail and Carol, too. I've lost all the girls that sit at Dawn's lunch table at school. I'm all alone, and I have nowhere to sleep tonight.
喷泉边的长椅空着，直觉告诉我，如果我失去了道恩，我也失去了盖尔和卡罗尔。我失去了所有在学校里和道恩坐在一桌吃饭的女孩。我孤身一人，今晚无处可睡。
I go into Anthony's and buy three slices with pepperoni with the last of my money. I eat as fast as I can, with warm grease dripping down my neck. My throat burns with swallowing so fast.
我走进安东尼披萨店，用身上剩下的钱买了三片意大利辣香肠披萨。我拼命地吃，温热的油脂顺着脖子流下。喉咙因为吞咽太快而灼烧。
Inside the Sears bathroom there are two girls at the sink. I don't know them. One girl has her head back, and the other is French braiding her hair. Best friends. When they see me, one of them reaches up, turns on the hand dryer to shut me out.
西尔斯百货的洗手间里，有两个女孩在洗手池旁。我不认识她们。一个女孩仰着头，另一个在帮她编法式辫。最好的朋友。当她们看到我时，其中一人伸手打开了干手机，要把我隔绝在外。
I go into a stall and lean over the bowl, one hand holding onto the toilet paper roll. The other hand turns into a knife. I stick it down into my throat until my stomach starts to shake and my mouth gags open, and the pizza rushes back up me and down, splashing into the bowl.
我走进隔间，俯身对着马桶，一只手抓着卫生纸卷。另一只手变成了一把刀。我把它伸进喉咙里，直到胃部开始颤抖，嘴巴干呕张开，披萨涌了上来，又吐了出来，溅进马桶里。
The hand dryer clicks off. One of the girls says, "Lisa should never wear yellow. Have you noticed that? She looks like a frog in yellow. It's weird."
干手机停了。其中一个女孩说：“丽莎真不该穿黄色的。你发现了吗？她穿黄色就像只青蛙。真奇怪。”
I lean against the wall of the stall, my head against the coat hook. My stomach feels thin and flat, empty. I let out a deep breath of air, and just for that one moment, between letting air out and filling myself up again, I feel beautiful, like a puzzle piece sliding in to fit. But then it's gone, and I flush the toilet and come out.
我靠在隔间的墙上，头顶着挂衣钩。胃里感觉又平又扁，空空如也。我长长地舒了一口气，就在那一刻，在呼气和再次吸气之间的空档，我感到自己很美，就像一块拼图滑入槽位刚好契合。但瞬间那感觉就消失了，我冲掉马桶，走了出去。
"Skanks" was by Rennie Sparks. Music was by The Handsome Family.
《混蛋》由雷尼·斯帕克斯演唱。音乐由“英俊家庭”乐队创作。
[MUSIC - "I ENJOY BEING A GIRL"]
[音乐 - “我喜欢做个女孩”]
Act Three, Good Girl.
第三幕，乖女孩。
Well, our program today about teenage girls comes to a close with this last story from radio producer Greg Whitehead, who lives in Massachusetts. This story is called "This Mindless Thing." Again, some content in this story may not be suitable for younger listeners.
好的，我们今天关于少女的节目，就以广播制作人格雷格·怀特海德带来的最后一个故事结束，他住在马萨诸塞州。这个故事题为《这无心之物》。再次提醒，本节目的部分内容可能不适合年幼听众。
I was 13, and he was 15. And we were going to go to the movies. We went to the Blue Star shopping center on Route 22 to see Live or Let Die. And I think his mother drove us. And we sat in the movie next to each other, and he didn't make a move. And nothing happened. And then his father came and picked us up and drove us back to his house.
当时我13岁，他15岁。我们打算去看电影。我们去了22号公路上的蓝星购物中心看《生死关头》。我想是他妈妈开车送我们去的。我们并排坐在电影院里，他什么举动也没有。什么都没发生。然后他爸爸来接我们，把我们送回了他家。
So he said, "Do you want to come up to my room?" And as we went into his room, he closed the door and said, "We're not allowed to lock our doors in my house." So otherwise he would have locked the door.
于是他说：“你想上我房间坐坐吗？”当我们走进他房间时，他关上门说：“在我家，我们不准锁门。”否则他肯定会把门锁上的。
This is really hard.
这真的很难说出口。
So I don't know. He roamed around and was showing me stuff, and I was just being sort of polite. And showing me all his toys and junk and silly things that he had, and then proceeded to make the moves, make the big moves on me. And I was just very innocent. And he was very aggressive and just started kissing me and then just said, "Take off your shirt."
我不知道该怎么办。他在房间里晃来晃去，向我展示各种东西，我只是出于礼貌应付着。他给我看了他所有的玩具、杂物和那些傻玩意儿，接着就开始有所动作，对我动手动脚。我当时非常天真。他很有攻击性，开始吻我，然后直接说：“脱掉你的衬衫。”
And so I'm sitting there thinking, well, the door is unlocked. And he said, "Well, you know--" And he had a little sister who was pestering us.
我坐在那儿心想，门没锁。他说，“嗯，你知道……”他有个小妹妹一直在打扰我们。
So eventually I said, [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] And he's like, "Oh, no." And asks me do I want to see it. I did. And of course, I want to see it. I mean, I want to know what it looks like. But at the same time, I feel like I'm in this incredibly ominous-- this is a dangerous situation. It's pornographic. Now I know how much of a little girl I was. I was just 13. I mean, 13 is young.
所以最后我说，[无法理解的短语]。他就像是说，“哦，不。”并问我想不想看看那个东西。我想看。当然，我想看。我是说，我想知道它长什么样。但同时，我觉得自己置身于一种极其不详的氛围中——这是一种危险的情况。这是色情。现在我知道当时的我是多么像个小女孩。我才13岁。我是说，13岁还很小。
But there it was, it was this mindless thing. And I thought, well [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] --I want to see it jump, this is what I have to do.
但它就在那儿，这件无心之物。我想，好吧[无法理解的短语]——我想看它跳动，这就是我必须做的。
So yeah, so he whips it out. And we both sit and we look at it.
所以，是的，他把它掏了出来。我们两个就坐在那儿看着它。
And he says, "Well, do you want to touch it?"
然后他说：“怎么样，你想摸摸看吗？”
And I didn't want to, but I did to get to a safe place. It was just horrible and dirty. More dirty than anything I've ever done since, even trying to be dirty. It was clinical, and I felt like I was being experimented upon. And the worst thing was that I was so passive. And I did what I was told, because I was a good girl. It was like a game to him.
我其实不想，但我为了表现得“安全”一点还是摸了。那真是太恐怖、太肮脏了。比我之后做过的任何事都脏，即便是在试图做坏事的时候。那过程像是一场实验，我感觉自己像个实验品。最糟糕的是，我当时太被动了。我照他说的做了，因为我是个乖女孩。对他来说，那就像一场游戏。
Now that I'm older, now that I think about it, it was a game. It wasn't playful. It was a very sophisticated game. It was a game. And it wasn't loving to coerce someone or to seduce someone-- or to seduce a little girl. It was as if he were 40.
现在我长大了，回头想想，那确实是一场游戏。那并不单纯。那是一场非常老练的游戏。那是个游戏。诱惑某人，诱惑一个小女孩，这并非出于爱。他表现得就像个40岁的成年人。
So here was this mindless thing. And he would look at me and think that I had been curious. "Want to see it jump?" So he could make it move. And flop around all by itself.
所以这就是那个无心之物。他会看着我，以为我很好奇。“想看它跳吗？”所以他能让它动起来。让它自己在那儿晃荡。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[嘈杂声]
--mindless thing, but it has a mind of its own and a body of its own. It sort of moved around. And I was just appalled. I had no idea that this was what happened, that you could make it move all by itself, without touching it. And that it just stood up, stood straight up. It was like his little ventriloquist dummy that he could make talk to me.
——无心之物，但它却有自己的思想，有自己的身体。它自己在那里动来动去。我简直震惊了。我根本不知道会发生这种事，不知道你竟然可以让它在不接触的情况下自己动起来。它竟然直接站了起来，笔直地竖着。就像是他腹语表演的木偶，他可以让它跟我对话。
It wasn't playful. It wasn't erotic. It wasn't loving. We put our clothes back on.
那不调皮。那不色情。那不充满爱。我们重新穿上了衣服。
My mother came and picked us up. And I walked outside on his nice suburban lawn. I just wanted to get out of there. And his mother was there, and my mother was talking to his mother. And I stared at our mothers.
我妈妈来接我们了。我走在他家漂亮的郊区草坪上。我只想离开那儿。他妈妈在那里，我妈妈正和他妈妈说话。我盯着我们的母亲们看。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[嘈杂声]
If they knew what had been going on. I just wanted to get out of there, to get to a safe place. But then I knew I could never tell anyone what had happened. So I could never be in a safe place.
如果她们知道发生了什么。我只想离开那儿，去一个安全的地方。但我知道我永远不能告诉任何人发生了什么。所以我永远无法身处安全之地。
[MUSIC - "THANK HEAVEN FOR LITTLE GIRLS" BY MAURICE CHEVALIER]
[音乐 - 莫里斯·舍瓦利耶演唱的《感谢上帝赐予小女孩》]
Could we have chosen a more creepy song than this one to put at this place in our program? I do not think so.
我们还能在这个节目的这个位置选出一首比这更令人毛骨悚然的歌吗？我想是不可能了。
Anyway, our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and by myself, with Peter Clowney, Alix Spiegel, and Dolores Wilber. Contributing editors, Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, and the fabulous Margy Rochlin.
总之，今天的节目由南希·厄普代克和我制作，参与人员还有彼得·克罗尼、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和多洛雷斯·威尔伯。特约编辑：保罗·托夫、杰克·希特和了不起的玛吉·罗克林。
Musical help with today's show from Chicago DJ John Connors and from the mysterious and elusive Rumpty Rattles. Original musical scoring under Rennie Sparks' story by The Handsome Family.
今天节目的音乐协助来自芝加哥DJ约翰·康纳斯，以及神秘而难以捉摸的Rumpty Rattles。雷尼·斯帕克斯故事的原创配乐由“英俊家庭”乐队完成。
If you'd like a copy of this program, it only costs $10. That's 10. You can call us at WBEZ to get one. 312-832-3380. That's 312-832-3380. Or you can email us. All emails get answered. Eventually. The address, [email protected] .
如果您想要本节目的拷贝，仅需10美元。就是10美元。您可以致电WBEZ获取一份。号码是312-832-3380。再次重复，312-832-3380。或者您可以发电子邮件给我们。所有的邮件都会得到回复。总会回复的。地址是 [email protected] 。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. I'm Ira Glass.
WBEZ管理监督：托里·马拉蒂亚。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Time to hit the pit?
是时候去休息了吗？
You bet. We'll be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
当然。下周我们将带着更多《美国生活》的故事回归。